[Música]
se puede esperar todo y nada porque
igual que este país bolsonaro es una
persona muy imprevisible le hemos visto
hoy llegando a primera de la mañana al
palacio de gobierno El palacio
del plan alto con cara de muy pocos
amigos se dice los bastidores Jesús
aliados le estarían presionando para que
se pronuncie no se sabe por qué este
silencio endurecedor y también los
mismas Fuentes dicen que también le
están presionando para que no
conteste los resultados en realidad
Incluso el ejército las fuerzas armadas
han reconocido que la democracia es
Sagrada y que no se pueden contestar
estos resultados una parte de sus
equipos de campaña le estaría culpando a
él personalmente de la derrota por haber
hecho más caso a Lala ideológica que a
la política de su campaña Es decir para
ver abrazado causas más radicales además
ha habido episodios
para anterior a los comicios como el
congresista que lanzó Granada sobre la
policía o la otra congresista también
aliada de bolsonaro que apuntó una
pistola contra un militante del PT del
partido de los trabajadores que habrían
terminado de hundir un poco su
credibilidad Mientras tanto en las redes
sociales en la noticia del día es que
Michelle bolsonaro la esposa de
bolsonaro habría dejado De seguirla en
instagram a él a por sonar a su marido y
también a su hijo Carlos y que bolsonaro
también habría dejado de seguir a su
esposa obviamente es un cotilleo pero
que dice mucho sobre un presidente que
vivió por y para las redes sociales y en
los bastidores se habla de una posible
crisis